whenever want to tie them ready okay
good so welcome to everyone who is
listening in so welcome to a new day of
talks today's gonna be exciting so we
start with the talk on quantum PCPs and
the randomization and then later we have
three talks about MIT started and I
think that there's a little team that is
going on because you can look out for a
lot of PC peace probabilistic stackable
proofs and also sort of transformations
that preserve the gap or amplify the gap
analysis talk we'll see them in the
context of local hamiltonians
and later in the context of non-local
games so okay without further ado let me
introduce the speaker we have Alex
Grillo from CWI and cue soft in
Amsterdam and take it away so thank you
everyone for joining in thanks for the
organizers for that snap is wonderful
this wonderful workshop and okay that's
I'm very proud to be here this my first
after-dinner talk so and out explain my
joint work with 32 had an all on this
connect and an expected connection
between quantum PCBs in the organization
and these are two very important open
problems in complexity theory and now
try to explain from beginning from
scratch what they are so we know there
are a lot of settings we're running out
hops a lot so as we saw for instance
last like yesterday in andreas talk for
instance if you have no local games
the referee must speak random questions
to send to their peers but we know that
at least to expect that the relevance
won't help in every case so for instance
we expected for polynomial time
competition random course does not do
not help and you can see these big
for instance a pseudo-random number
generators exist then everyone demised
autism can be turning to other terminus
big ones and the existence of
pseudo-random number generators is
supported for widely believed
conjectures in complexity theory so it's
a bit embarrassing because we know that
it should be true that it has been an
open problem for a very long time and
just to I don't know who's in the
audience but for those who have never
seen about demons do randomization let
me give an example of why why it's hard
to randomize problems or do analyze
algorithms are and one example is in
this problem called the polynomial until
test and in this problem the input is a
polynomial P on let's say want some cute
parrot few that Q and the input is n Q
to the N and then it outputs some
element in our Q and this polynomial has
degree at most P and you want to know if
for every possible input of this
polynomial it evaluates to 0 and you can
think that here this polynomial is given
in an implicit way so for instance you
have a circuit that computes this
polynomial and there is a very simple
rule no matter what is that is the
following so you just pick the input to
the public triangle and try to evaluate
this polynomial 0 and if indeed this
polynomial is 0 for every possible input
it will be 0 for this randomly chosen
one but what we can show this is the
polynomial at 0 then if you pick one of
these such inputs uniform at random then
with high probability you won't hit a 0
so this these simple randomized
algorithm somehow allows us to find such
a witness that this Pauline order is not
0 and we don't know how to do it
analytically no no don't know how to
search for for these witnesses or infer
these disables a without
run on coins and in this talk I'm
interested in this in their limitations
Mario when you're talking about the
verification of uh proofs and product we
have we start to set the complexity
class NP that you might know that let me
recall it so we say that a problem is in
and B if if there is a deterministic
medical another time verification
algorithm D and receives X that the
instance that you want to know if it's a
positive in terms of negative instance
of this empty problem and Y which is
called a certificate or a witness and
the deterministic algorithm on input x
and y i decide to accept or reject and
the engine NT is for every positive
instance there are these some some
witness that makes deterministic
algorithm to accept and for no instances
no matter which witness is given to the
deterministic algorithm it should reject
and is a central objecting complex issue
and even in computer science so it has
been extended in different contexts and
one of such concept context is in
randomized computation and then we have
the the randomized version of and deal
that's called MA and it stands for a
Merlin error term and here it's almost
the same thing as an EP but now this
verification outwardly is a polynomial
time random competition time random
conditioner and that's given again one
instance that you want to know if it's
positive or negative
and a witness that that should be
verified by this randomized algorithm
and here we want to that four year
synthesis that they are resistant in
witness that to make this randomized
computation except with high probability
whereas for no aces no matter what is
what women is given these randomized
algorithm should reject each other baby
and when I think is that who can also
can improve a little bit this first line
for CB instances you can assume without
loss of generality but it is one like
there's a serum dripping that and every
day as I said before even in the NT
purses that may case we believe this to
complexify stupidest thing so randomized
Fantasia wouldn't help even for
verifying proofs but again this problem
has been open for a long time and in one
life our result in this work is showing
that some sort of quantum PCP conjecture
is equivalent to the randomization of
the name and all wait five seconds for
if there's any question on the
definition of an anma
by the way if you have questions you can
as usual write them in the Q&A or you
can raise your hand and I'll unmute you
okay if there are no questions so I'll
explain a bit better what our result is
and for that I have to make a detour in
Hamiltonian complexity so we know that
for quantum mechanics that the
devolution of physical systems are
described by hamiltonians and one very
important problem in condensed matter
physics is finding what the
configuration of the particles that
minimizes the energy of such hamilton in
this configuration of particles is
called the ground state of that of that
hamilton and nature you have part of
that are far apart they tend not
interact so usually this global jiménez
they can be decomposed at the sum of
smaller terms and our goal here is
trying to study this problem through the
lens of our chair computer science and
for that we let me define this problem
or Forman
so we assume that the input of today
we had the diesel talks as a problem
sorry
okay so I heard something No so we have
that the the input of such problem is em
loco Hamiltonians and I say they are
local because each of them acts on at
most k out of n cubed system and for
those who are not so familiar with of
eternal so meaning that there K loco it
needed a chai is a better product of
identity and these are term a chai tilde
X or at most K cubits and Hamiltonian is
nothing more than a hermitian matrix so
we can think of just some matrix that is
self adjoint and also we assume that
each one of these terms has bound an arm
let's say that bad alarm is bounded by
one and giving this M local terms we
considered Indiglo Bahamut or inherited
an H at the some of these local firms
and our book here is distinguishing to
case the first one when the recent state
that has low energy according to this
Hamiltonian so it below some threshold
alpha N or they decide if every state
has high energy so for every state the
energy of the habitat needs to be above
some threshold battalion and for those
also probably respect on these were just
talking about what take smallest eigen
value of these emission matrix and in
complexity theory or okay given a
problem we want to understand how hard
this problem is and in order to explain
the hardness of this local measurement
problem I'll go back to the complexity
class and I have to define the quantum
version of mmm so this is called the
complexity class TMA and this complexity
class it changes because now the
verification algorithm is a quantum
algorithm it received as before they
they input the instance of the problem
but now it also receives a quantum proof
that will allow this quantum
verification algorithm to access
and now we want that for all positive
instance there is a critical state that
makes this quantum verification
algorithm accesses high probability and
for no instances we have that all parts
of states makes this quantum
verification algorithm reject this high
probability and here differently from
the probability case we don't know if
it's possible to assume without loss of
generality that for a yes case we can
make it one I will stop for three
seconds if there's any questions on
qmail ok so back to the local home
Italian problem so as I tell you I think
we just call your question the questions
how should we think of K and M with
respect to n what is the intersecting
range of parameters so K the constant
let say K is 5 and what another
parameter and the other parameters n oh
oh
n is the size of her your system so you
fix N and then the number of terms is
polynomial in n so so it'll be different
from what we have visual in computer
size n is the number of qubits oh but K
is a concept as I said it's files here
and so in again we were okay what we
want is to decide if the energy that
there is a state with low energy or all
the states have high energy orbitals
come upon and T type showed in 99 that
if you pick bit an alpha to be at least
an inverse polynomial so this problem is
actually given a complete meaning first
that is it is in QA and CUNY
verification come to a problem like the
prover just gives this supposed to be
low energy state to the verifier and
notification algorithm just checks if
the energy is more large and what did I
have also showed is that this problem is
really hard showing what we call the
quantum book live in here and reduce
every problem generic problem in QA to
an instance of the local Hamiltonian
problem and now that you have the
disparage ma complete you can think okay
/ KU for which range of parameters that
it remains you may complete or for which
range of parameters it it becomes easy
and for is a very important set of
parameter is when beta minus alpha is a
constant so here you have a much bigger
gap between a get an oasis so it should
be a much easier problem that the
contour PCP conjectures tasted even with
this very large gap this problem remains
Jimmy Hart any question so given the
importance and application of low
kilometers in quantum computing people
also start to study or how hard is this
problem is when it does consider like
the arbitrary internals but restricted
families of global habitants and one
family that was considered for a far
this trip restricted local army terminal
is what called stochastic Hamiltonians
and the definition is a bit
counterintuitive but just just divided
by Hamilton is called stochastic if
every H I have has non positive of
diagonal elements so the diagonal could
be pleasing that diagonal with either 0
or a negative value and the first thing
that you notice is that this definition
is based dependent but we assume that
were given this Hamiltonian in the bases
were such a phenomenal Kurtz and why
people have considered it is because
these models the first machines that
were developed by the way and I said
this definition is a bit counter TVs but
they
it has very nice consequences so instead
of considering this locus the
Hamiltonian H I who could instead
consider the projector and with it
ground space and the capacity of
Hamiltonian gives us very nice
properties for this projector in
particular it allows us to to write it
is as a sum over orthogonal projection
of Rank 1 projectors okay since it's a
projector it can always be like this
that every every each one of these Rank
1 projectors is spanned by the subspace
spanned by a state with only real no
negative amplitudes so here so P is a
sum over projections over positive
states or no negative states are and
this implies that this hamiltonian h
stage it must have some ground state
that only contains no negative
amplitudes and that's why they call the
term stochastic because somehow you can
see these amplitudes there's no negative
attitude as a probability distribution
so it is something between stochastic
the cuts in stochastic a materials and
fully quantum ones any question about
the definition of stochastic Hamiltonian
so in this work we will receive even
more this kind of stochastic Hamiltonian
and in consider what we call uniform
stochastic economies and in these the
standard Hamiltonian we consider the
only states in this runtime project that
only contain the same amplitude so we
can just go our consider sets of strings
and this state is just a uniform
proposition over the top string and then
the display is a sum over there what you
call this subset States and this has
another nice
consequence in the ground state now we
can prove that there
now say that is just a union from super
position over the strings in some that
some set s okay and for the purpose of
this talk these are the types of
acronyms that will be considered so
having defined these stochastic our
materials we can okay go back to the
local hominem problem and study what
happens to the hardness of the problem
when we when you know that the input are
stochastic a McCombs when when they
could have given to you they are
stochastic and here we also want to
sober be easier problem we want to
decide if this happy turning has some
state with energy Dido and sometimes we
call it the reason attorneys
prescription free display or if they
drunk energy of the semi-trailer so
though this malice smallest eigen value
of H is at least ambit I'm for some
parameter data and again we want to
understand how hard is this problem so
then in 2008 bra enter how they show
that for some inverse polynomial beta
this problem is I'm a complete so this
is very surprising for two reasons so
first it is the first aim a complete
problem so it has been defined for more
than 13 years and then the first natural
complete problem for this class class
and second be the first one it comes
from cones computations so I think it's
very surprising the connection between
quantum and randomized computation and
here the only hardness of this of this
problem comes more or less for free
thought from their from the from the
result from hospital and they're really
not a novelty here comes from proving a
disturbance in MA in particular that you
you can decide between these two cases
which only classical always use the toss
coins Alex there's a question from the
chat yeah is there any restriction on s
I guess
was on the on the rest can be any subset
I guess this was from the previous slide
here no no I said no I'm just saying
that so here is okay what are a claim
here that there is a brown page this is
a bear at least of s such the ground
state is a universal superposition over
they streamed in us that's just a claim
that the researcher master studies this
works okay so as I was saying so for for
me with polynomial better driving their
house show that these problems they may
complete and our result here is showing
that if beta is actually a constant for
it could be any constant then this
problem is actually an NP so if you have
a promise that this gap between ethanol
which is much larger that is bullied
coins to solve the problem we can solve
deterministically given some proof given
some initial some classical food and for
the rest of this talk explain a bit more
disconnection between habitat and
complex changes randomization and then
now go into a bit more technical details
between like how to show that so far
Lokar meter in a varying na and finally
give a proof sketch of my result is that
it and finally I will finish with some
open problems so let me put our result
and the result by the aventure house
side by side so they show that deciding
if the income so passive account owner
has brown energy 0 or inverse polynomial
is an a complete and the only difference
to our result is not and then now the
gap is between 0 and constant and then
we are allowed to show that is in NP
so let's suppose that there exists some
deterministic polynomial time map not
hamachi from attorneys to stochastic
Hamiltonians with the following
properties so the output is that
uniforms to pass the component and when
K is a constant and also a parameter
that I didn't define the degree is also
constant so the output is nicely behaved
Alex sorry to intervention in the child
so the Dominic asked what does uniform
mean in those theorems Oh uniform is
what I said that I assume that the terms
are this t IJ like is the disjoint point
projectors
they are all subsets stages of any
arbitrary non-negative state is fine so
as I said that I want that the output of
this map v to be to be a nice suppose to
come eternal and we wondered if the
input Hamiltonian is a stochastic a
meter of ground energy 0 the output has
also brought an energy 0 okay so if
there's more second value of H is 0 this
value eigen value of x prime is also 0
and if H has got energy inverse
polynomial for something fixed
polynomial then we want that this the
ground energy of this H prime that the
output of this map is constant in this
map in complex issue is called a gap
investigation procedure so it's
amplifying the gap that the promised gap
from H and now it's bigger in this H
prime so you have that if this gap of
limitation procedure exists then ma goes
empty and let me describe why this fall
so we can start with a problem MA
and we're both winter Hall we can reduce
this problem in MA towards the plastic
Oklahoma tunnel instance
where they promised gap is universally
known then from the assumption of this
magpie we can reduce the this instance
to instance of this to positive comment
on a problem where now the promise gap
is a constant but what is surely now
result is that for every constant this
can be solved the empty so if such a map
exists that we don't that is the only
part we have that every problem you make
is easy in NP and it seems to go to the
back seems too good to be true then why
does it exist so we know that for
classical Hamiltonians
they exist and this is exactly the PCP
theorem so that you cannot we can have a
gap identification procedure for for
classical Hamiltonian the quantities to
go chapter or then it is it conjectures
that such a map exists for general
Hamiltonian so this map that were
considering here that I just defined it
can be seen that play stochastic pacific
conjecture so we want that this map that
gathereth amplification exists for only
first across the continents and then it
shown that these two paths PPP
conjecture is the equivalent of the
randomized naming and then could fill
this in two ways so when you can see
that our water we are dancing in the MA
% e problem so we have a new way of
attacking this problem that you can do
it through quantum argument so showing
that is too fast
pipi conjecture exists or if that's true
but a different way of seen it is that
actually proving quando PCP should be
very hard because in particular previous
some source of quantum recipes would be
also solving the organization we know
that the very very hard question can I
have a question here
so yeah you had some some like extra
conditions on on this map so like how
natural are those so it seems that like
some specific version of store
stick PCP is equivalent this a make was
MP problem but one could maybe imagine
that some I doesn't preserve perfect
completeness or something so about
completeness I'll say something more
about the end that it's true that okay
it's not that any identification map
pudding pie ma goes and peas just like a
communication procedure with these
properties but ok one thing that makes
us hope is because the classical gap
amplification procedure has these
properties for instance so III think
yeah I'll say I'll say different
problems the way of so with this it's
showing that the stochastic low-carb
Italian problem is in NP for a broader
set of parameters this would this would
make this this reduction more flexible
sorry another question isn't it possible
that one could prove a the general
quantum PCP conjecture but without
proving the stochastic PCP conjecture
yes it can so yeah in this way you can
see this is some somewhat as about a
year so if you want you can sell quantum
PCP without to solve any recommendation
by either putting signs or losing
perfect completed so that there are ways
of solving quantity C B's but you can
you can see these as a barrier of
tripping them so without solving very
hard problems okay thanks so so let me
continue and then no I want to talk a
bit how graphing clear how they show
that these stochastic
how materials they can be solved in mmm
and for that they depend in some
implicit graph and so if the Hamiltonian
action and L cubed n cubed system then
the vertices of this verse are just they
all the possible n bit strings so that's
why it's implicit because it's an
exponential size graph and we connect to
two vertices in this graph if they
belong to the same projector of the
location explain these bags a boy to be
more clear I think so imagine a to have
a three cubed system and you have three
local terms and here I'll define just
the projector on to the down space of
these local terms the term on action on
qubit one and to this projector is
penned by the state's website 0 or size
0 0 or plus on 0 and Phi Phi 0 where Phi
0 is 0 0 plus 1 1 and tensor identity on
the third cubic and the same thing for
people 3 well now we have our implicit
tensor identity on the first qubit and
finally in this is the projector of
these grounds of this Hamiltonian on the
first and third qubit is 10 by j the
state 0 0 0 1 and 1 0 and this here you
have a 3 cubed system because our graph
you have all these all the possible
few bit strings and let's say for
instance look at the node 0 0 0 and for
instance if you look to the projection
p12 we see that 0 0 is a neighbor of 1 1
so we keep the third bit but we can't
change the substring 0 their initial
substring 0 0 by 1 1 and we connect
these two vertices integral the same
thing happens for P 2 3 we still have
that 0 0 is the same ground state of 1 1
so we connect the vertices where we
monitoring the first qubit which are the
first bit that will change the the last
two bits from 0 0 to 1 1 and final P 1 3
0 0 does not have neighbors so we don't
need to add any extra edge because of
country
having defined is worth driving her home
they also define a notion called bad
strings in a string X is said to be bad
if there is some some Hamiltonian such
that X is not in the ground state of
data maternal so in particular if you
look to the string 1 0 1 and 1 1 1 you
see that 1 1 is not in P 1 3 so the
strings 1 0 1 and 1 1 1
they must be bad because they never
projecting to so having defined these
implicit graph so preventer how they
define what they may verification
procedure and here it is the
verification procedure it assumes that
the proving or someone gives as an proof
of the that they are metering
infrastructure have energy 0 i initial
string at 0 that's supposed to be in the
ground state of this hamilton and the
verification algorithm just perform the
run amok on that implicit graph for
pauline normally many stats and this can
be done efficiently finally this
verification algorithm will Jack if and
only if a bad string is encountered in
this random walk so getting back to
example so if you start with 0 0 0 we
could let's say it has two edges so it
could be for instance 2 1 1 0 because of
the edge added by because of P 1 2 but
then from 1 1 0 with some weight have
you move to 1 0 1 because of the
projector of the because of the local
term on qubits 2 & 3
but when 0 1 is a bad string so they may
be regression over the mood would
retract in this case
and what broaden to how they show is
that if the this Hamiltonian has gone
energy zero so another words it's
frustration-free and X 0 is indeed some
string in the ground state of the
Hamiltonian let me brief and then what
they show that the very file never reach
the bad string and this happens because
the connected component of they can show
that the connected component of this
string only contain good string so you
can never have any path from this X 0 in
the ground state to a bathroom and then
for salmon be sure that if the ground
energy of this I return is at least an
inverse polynomial then if you're run a
walk is big enough so into but still
polynomial it should verification are
awkward which actually constant
probability and the idea why this hold
is because somehow they came they cancel
it this the ground energy is related to
the expansion in this in these implicit
graph and then you should give enough
steps when you should cover you should
pass by a bathroom when you consider as
we did the purpose of the case what we
are allowed like our main technical Emma
is showing that if the Hamiltonian spell
frustrated then when you consider this
bath for every stream that to peak in
this graph or every vertex that you big
there is a bad string are very close to
two to two or treat
so in particular every string contains a
bad shrink in a constant radius ball
around it and this gives directly that
that shown that is uniform Sebastian
Oklahoma torn and with constant promise
gap is in any peak because the previous
initial string that's supposed to be in
the ground state of the Hamiltonian and
the verifier just determine easily will
first search for a bad 3 on its
neighborhood
and this can be done efficiently because
the number of neighbors is polynomial
and the path that you want is constant
size and if it is a assistance as Aliya
braaap inter Hokkaido with any path
starting from the screen geographic
wouldn't want to reach about drink so we
never reject but from our lemma no
matter what's the initial string sent by
the program we know the berries of a
string on its neighborhood so this
brute-force search must find it and it
plays this video the verify we will
check with our q1 there's no probability
to always reject any question so I'll
tell a bit more now about the structure
of our proof and it has two main sets
first we show that there is a constant
at what we call circuit of projectors
that achieves the state with a bad
string I'll explain it later water water
animator and we find such a conducted in
incremental way so we showed it either
we have a state we start with a state
that contains a bad string or you can
find this set of non-overlapping
projectors that will move us closer to
having I stayed with a bad string then
assuming that cosine Phi stupid
projections you could exist that lead us
to up a string then you can use the
light con argument to retrieve constant
size path from it so let me explain here
in more details so we know that the Blue
Room is to focus on the initial string
x1 the support
to begin the ground set of Muhammad Amin
but we know that cemetery is highly
frustrated so there there are two
options either this string X 1 is bad
which K is real done we have a bad
string or what you can show is that you
can find a lot of local terms that when
you consider their projection of their
ground space projector of x1 on to its
ground space it the perceptron to its
graph space we have a 3 or higher
content status pool that contains much
more string so the support of the string
is in as to it exponentially bigger of
course I'm for selecting for selecting
on on this project on this projection
and then we can ask ourselves again this
has to contain a bad string if it
contains up a string again we are done
because that's what you want I stayed
with a bad streak but if that's not how
you can find another layer of
projections that will lead us to some
post selected status tree that contain
again exponentially more strings than
the status 2 and again you cannot go
again there's a three containers of a
drink and you continue like that
and at every time we add exponentially
more strings to this state so at some
point after coffee many steps we have to
have reached all possible strings right
because at some point this exponential
got to 2 to the N and when it gets to
the end since we have the assumption
that the simultaneous highly frustrated
then there must be at least on that
string in the in mistake it has a lot of
them so it has at least one so with
these we can show that this like with
these projections on the ground nor with
these on overlapping reactions we can
reach X 1 to a state with a pachinko
streaming
and I'll always five seconds for any
question
okay so let me explain a bit more in
details how how these extra expansion
works so for that we will Emma that you
call a one-term expansion lemon and for
this lemma we assume that you have some
subset date so I stated that the uniform
superposition over some stray of strings
and B being this K low cost coffee
projector meaning that case open
projector of projector onto the ground
base of a Kahlo pasta pasta can
determine any of you mouth so that s
does not contain any bedroom for for mr.
jumpy okay we also silver pin shrink the
state as we subset paid us by at least
one minus Delta factor
so assuming all of these having Alois
assumptions we show that if you wanna
project P whenever right s on to P the
number of strings in the support of this
postal act at stake is at least is
related to the frustration that we had
according to this projection and the
inclusion of the proof in the following
so we know that this is this projection
so else does not lie in the plus 1 again
space over of projection is 100 minus
Delta proud from it but s does not
contain any bad string for P so this
frustration must come from what we call
missing screen so streams that are
neighbors from strings of s but they are
outside of it and project you entropy
will exactly add these missing strings
is dealt over to as missing strings to
this side PS we can see this base and in
this part of our peers of the sent and
then what we do is use this argument in
parallel so we have this non overlapping
expansion lemma where
we start again with a subset state but
instead instead of having just one per
section we have let's say helpers at
first and every time you say that s
projected to be 1 through P API does not
contain any bad stream for pi plus 1 and
on top of that we show that when you
apply till I plus 1 on the post selected
state of pure apply s on p1 up to P I
this again with shrimp we said so this
post selected state is far from being
size 1 on a set apart from the other
Army's Delta far from being in the
ground space of PID from so assuming
this destructed state and these
projectors were able to show that the
support of s projecting to P 1 R 2 PL
the support of these the of this state
it has at least one minus Delta by 2 to
the L or more strings than s so if L is
linear in the number of terms then it
means that by finding such such no
non-overlapping stochastic projectors we
can increase the number of strings in
the state by an exponential factor and
the pieces are simple we just apply the
1 term expression L times and I went
back into details here and then the only
missing part is how to find this
non-overlapping detectors and this but
this is OK when you know it is very
simple it took us a long a long time to
find it but it's just an adaptive
argument because we know that the
Hamiltonian very frustrating so any
state that you have should be highly for
L so first if you have this poster like
the state from s of 2 pi they're
massively there must excuse up to I plus
1 that's how that frustrates this side
and then you can just about me at this
TI plus 1 to be set
okay
so this finishes the first part of the
proof and the second part of the proof
as I said is moving from this course on
that projection circuit into into a
precise path of in the integrand and a
nice property of this trick we did it
has constant that as I said but the
problem is every layer could have
polynomially many projections so from
this circuit we cannot directly find
Arco suffice path from X to a bad string
but we can do if we use the properties
of badness so here we have the a battery
is bad because it does not belong to the
ground state of a specific local term so
let's see that the bad part of the
string in this last state is the mark is
not here by rent
so when good thing about this the the
locality of the badness is that
everything that does not influence
whatever there this part is the second I
cannot influence the badness of I string
here so in particular if you can remove
every every projector on the last layer
that does not touch the bits of these of
the bits here in red it can be removed
and of course here will remove the
projectors so this day that we had here
has changed but this state must still
contain a bad stranger and then we can
repeat this argument over and over again
so we can remove from this second to
last relay here everything that does not
influence what influences this red part
so so in other words you remove
everything that is not in the light cone
of this red path so every time
you remove from a layer everything that
cannot influence the state on this red
part and since we assume that that we
have constant locality and cost some
degree we have it when you remove
everything that's not in this light cone
since this this circuit has gone from
the number of players in the circuit is
also constant it means that the number
of projectors that remain here
they are also constant so in particular
if you consider the subgraph induced by
these projections on on on on the graph
that we defined before it has only a
constant number of edges and by the way
that we chose these projections it not
be the case in this that we subgraph
this initial string X is connected to a
bad string on that small graph okay and
these allows us to to to retrieve from
these constant many projectors bad
shrink path from X to a bad string and
this finishes the idea of the second
part of the proof so we also have other
temecula so our domain result is having
these empty will put in in peace
deciding of stochastic low cognitive and
and self-assertion zero or a constant
but one thing that you can do is relax a
little bit and we don't need anymore
that today so party local agenda has
energy zero yeah we can decide if it's
tiny or constant so that will back a bit
to the question by interest and so this
guy complication map it does not need to
preserve
perfect completeness but it can but it
could just slightly disturb it and it
will still be fine
a second and more recent thing is that
we also realized that we can make you
can recognize the problem don't defy
like that the results are like all the
algorithms are classical that we
decompose the problem we are considered
the stochastic local kernels actually as
an extension of constraints obsession
problems but not for sets of strings let
me call this problem of a sad CSP
problem and by translating this the
result of lavender Hall in my risotto
studied in this in this language of such
as peace we have this communication for
this problem is also equivalent to a
Makos empty and I think this is a very
nice contribution because we also trust
the people they didn't they somehow they
didn't know about the existence of this
I make a good problem because it's
hidden in this constant language and
somehow we were able to translate into
some classical language and let me
finish with some open problems so the
for me the main event problem of our
result is try to prove or disprove these
coastal asked to speak on gesture and
okay some simpler questions to our this
is trying to prove containment the MP
for smell that so not necessarily for
24-hour constant that they were smaller
if anything bigger restoring log sorry
[Music]
log is this more but any and no as I
said we have the case that so we can
distinguish the case for between
tiny and large and can you move further
like you have a constant gap but now
further from it from from the initial
point zero like so like there for for
completeness we could be the say inverse
pulling an amateur in this polynomial or
even a constant a second thing would be
try to generalize our results to the
known in front case
and then we we have a part of our reward
would also follow for this donut from
Kaitlyn when these rank one projectors
are over arbitrary no negative states
but the problem that we face is that
they're then they the frustration for
the have eternal calm only from these
bad strings but it comes also from the
inconsistency of amplitudes and for
example if you have just for after
example well when you have just a one
cubit Hamiltonian and two terms on this
one it could be done it on and the first
term is 1 minus that song you know like
a projector on to the ground face is
down there on the Rankine projector 1
minus epsilon 0 plus 1 1 in the second
term is epsilon 0 plus 1 minus epsilon 1
so by our definition this infinite does
not continue in bed string but is some
attorneys highly frustrated because you
can never be almost in 0 and almost in
no one at the same time and we're winter
hardy they're able to deal with this but
as far as you see this is not they don't
do it in our walk away so we cannot
reproduce the way that they deal with it
in our case and finally the work of
preventer how they use their containment
in a in a different setting is the
setting of doing classical simulation of
adiabatic evolution of stochastic
awareness and I think it's an
interesting approach to see if our
result has some implication in this
topic as well and thank you for
attention
thank you ok so we have a time for some
questions you can write them in the chat
or raise your hand okay there is a
question in the chat you pon asked
if this classical definition can be
extended to frustrated cases namely a
combinatorial stochastic and may
complete problem problem yes it can
yeah yes it can but then a and it would
still be an a heart and it would still
be in MA like the biggest Yokohama
twinners can be translated or at least
uniform uniform so parameters can be
easy just translate it into this
language non-uniform ones could be also
translated but then you need to to tweak
a little bit this problem but all of
these results should should easily
translate I was curious also about
something so what's your feeling like do
you think that there could be an
approach to proving quantum PCP which
does not prove the stochastic PCP
there's also one point is that for
instance we show that this gap version
is in NP so in our case we're not very
surprised because we believe in a to be
cosine T so proven NP is somehow
expected whereas if you prove that get
quantum Hammond general quantum Etonians
in NP this somehow this proves the
quantum pacific conjecture because you
believe that TNA is different so the
first question is is that clear at least
not here to be that the Kanto Pacific
injector should be true so I think there
are a lot of people in the audience that
they maybe have more like they they know
more about things too to say that all
for me the first questions not clear at
all that the conjecture to the whole
question so on your side you write
disprove the stochastic PCP conjecture
but you proved you proved that actually
this this gap stochastic Hamiltonians
problem is np-complete right
yeah okay so so if you you know if
you're you know believe randomization
and if you saw that this universe poly
gap is not in NP like this is will be
disproving disproving this piece P
conjecture then if you prove that is
problem that we in MA is not in indeed
and you show that they may be more vague
so seems to me like this I don't really
understand this stochastic property I
mean you know you define it formally but
it seems like it's is it a basis
dependent definition yeah it is a base
dependent and there are a lot of two
results so by Jeff Passan
margin there Hall locator a lot of
authors are citing them that trying to
find the given a Hamiltonian is there a
basis that makes it be stochastic and
here I assume that these antennas are
given in these in the right pages they
see if you enter a button well I guess
it was kind of an open-ended question
like so suppose you know suppose someone
walked up with the family of
Hamiltonians that was still crossing in
some basis but you didn't know would you
be able to see so far we don't know so
if you don't know the basis and you
don't have any help telling all the
bases
to make it stochastic then give these
procedures they do not work at least not
really but what I think what Barbara and
bubbles in audience if she wants talk at
the most they show that some of these
problems are an in NP and in this case
this could come with the proof right
what the basis that make it stochastic
yeah I can well I guess basically it's
we only made a start on this problem and
the only basis transformations we looked
at our single qubit unit ares you know
if your hamiltonian is not obviously
stochastic you say I do apply single
human Terry's to try to make it
stochastic and then in some cases you
can prove that actually single qubit
clifford suffice which is a discrete
subsets and then you can ask and then
the problem is an MP because somebody
could give you that clifford if it
exists and and then in some cases we
also proved that for some Hamiltonian is
the problem of finding the unitary zyzz
that you generically we also show it's
np-complete you throw other classes but
the thing is that these single unit ares
are only one choice right you could
throw a constant depth circuit at it you
could throw a perturbation gadget at it
it's you know it's yeah it's a lot of
possible transformations but i think
alex results are indeed sort of
independent of that because in this case
you're given the Hamiltonian and the
basis it's just and you know its de
questing in the standard basis to
computational basis
can I ask a question Alex now that I'm
gonna sort of talking so maybe is asks
you this question before so what about B
P P and P so because you can also take
PPP write the Hamiltonian that's and
then you were able you have to control
so we can what you can show that this
like it is not also like if you have
extra property for this map then you can
attack this then it shows that our P it
is equal to P so one-sided putting over
randomized algorithms are equivalent to
P we cannot show for bpp
and this is because you don't know so in
some sense like when you're talking
about the about the the random walk we
don't know what the warm start because
it's like there are two side errors and
our P you can do it so we don't know
forbidden Thanks thank you
okay good if there are no more questions
and let's take the speaker s and Alex
again we can clap visually in the chat